[Musique]
peu importe la diète la quête est la
même perdre ces quelques kilos en trop à
long terme les diètes amaigrissante ont
un très faible taux de réussite
c'est ce qu'a démontré la nutritionniste
karine gravel dans sa thèse de doctorat
à peu près 85 94 % des personnes qui
vont reprendre le poids perdu deux ans
après la fin de la diète le 2 ans ou
plus donc le taux d'échec est
extrêmement élevé connais personne qui
peut suivre une diète indéfiniment là on
finit toujours par se fatiguer se lasser
de ce truc de base que je dis toujours
aux gens pisi quand il m'arrive avec une
nouvelle diète une nouvelle charge la
première question c'est est ce que tu
crois être capable de maintenir sa vie
pas pour un an deux ans comme tout le
temps tout le temps ce soir si la
réponse est non mais c'est pas la bonne
solution joanes gilbert est docteur en
kinésiologie et spécialiste de la
gestion du poids notre perception de
l'image corporelle dans la société
d'aujourd'hui qui nous pousse vers un
espèce d'image parfaite couper au
couteau tout à fait réelle puis même
retouché énormément par ordinateur mais
c'est là où est ce que ça vient faire
une espèce de distorsion entre notre
image à nous puisqu'on voit donc une des
factions d'image corporelle
[Applaudissements]
le marché mondial des diètes c'est plus
de 300 milliards de dollars dépensés
l'an dernier en aliment miracle
substitut doit pas livre de recettes au
programme minceur
c'est la seule de ses échecs à nous
faire croire qu'il ya quelque chose
qu'on a fait de pas correct si jamais on
a appris le poids perdu alors que veste
et le mécanisme qu'on doit remettre en
question presque une femme sur deux est
au moins deux tentatives de perdre deux
fois par année si au moins deux ça peut
être plus que ça c'est bien ça c'est
probablement à répétition c'est rare que
quelqu'un fait juste prix est un mythe
ressemblance avis
l'equilibre le corps ses soutiens donc
de faire changer souvent le poids ça
amène plus de problèmes de santé
malheureusement à long terme que de
maintenir un coup même s'il est élevé
parfois donc de faire beaucoup de yoyo
ses preneurs fermes en
plus d'être néfaste pour le corps et les
diètes amaigrissante avait pétition
provoque aussi des blessures
psychologiques talel des princes a
augmenté sa section corporelle ça
diminue l'estiment de soi aussi c'est
normal si on fait quelque chose de
semblable qui on est toujours dans une
situation d'échec mais on en vient à
penser qu'il ya quelque chose qu'on est
pauvre on crée
et si la solution était ailleurs que
dans les restrictions alimentaires ce
que je vais faire un kleenex commencé à
parler de la gestion du sommeil la
gestion du stress qui ont un impact sur
la santé et qui par là bas on pourrait
avoir un impact sur le poids
quand on change nos actes de vie pour
avoir les habitudes de 800 scène on va
se retrouver avec un poids qu'on appelle
naturel ou est-ce qu'ils occupent de
bataille contre le poids de bataille
contre la bourde de se forcer à tout
prix à les bouger puis par des
entraînements de fou quitte à se blesser
le plus ce que c'est réaliste sein de
d'imaginer qu'il ya un poids qui monte
garantir la santé si c'était si simple
que ça mais toutes les personnes qui ont
un poids plus élevé serait malade toutes
les personnes qui sont minces très en
bonne santé que c'est pas le code
si on remplaçait le pèse personne par le
plaisir de manger sans culpabiliser
c'est une approche et bienveillante une
approche positive on n'est pas dans le
contrôle essayé de respecter des règles
alimentaires je trouve ça intéressant
parce que ya comme une liberté dans
cette approche là où on voit davantage
écouter ce qui se passe à l'intérieur de
nous donc on l'alimentation intuitive
alice de conseil qui est très important
pour moi ça fait partie de
l'alimentation humaine et on peut le
manger de façon intuitive il mangeait
plus transformés et manger végétal donc
tout ça et les cohérences en cette
approche qu il n'y a plus de 20 ans par
deux nutritionnistes californienne est
fondé sur dix grands principes donc
rejeter la culture des diètes et faire
la paix avec les aliments en amérique du
nord nord un rapport très fonctionnel
alimentation très anxiogène se dirait
donc l'alimentation est une façon de
vivre plus longtemps d'avoir un corps
très svelte quand on dit qu'on n'est pas
d'aliments interdits savait pas dire de
manger n'importe quoi n'importe quand ça
veut dire puis donc vu ton plus se
sentir bien bien sûr on va manger des
aliments
puisqu'ils créent des aliments frits des
animaux plus grands mais dans une
quantité qui va peut-être qu'on va se
sentir comédien après les aliments ultra
transformer bien sûr que on veut les
limiter si les gens choisissent des
aliments plus entier - transformé ils
vont nécessairement manger moins manger
plus selon leurs besoins parce que ces
éléments sont harmonieux pour notre camp
ce les aliments qui encourage un
métabolisme favorables à la santé alors
que d'autres produits il enrichit en
sucre et en gras et en sel vont
davantage engendrer des effets
métaboliques qui vont être défavorable à
la santé l'idée avec l'alimentation
intuitif c'est aussi d'être à l'écouté
comme en ce sens c'est d'être connecté
avec son corps
on suggère aussi de ceux ci de
catégoriser les aliments
intéressant on mange pas des nutriments
on mange des aliments c'est important de
revenir à ce qu'on mange de façon
globale mais comme une tendance à manger
de l'est clément petit le manger des
protéines manger des glucides moi je dis
toujours ça goûte quoi se manger des
protéines et des glucides ces bains
plainte
évidemment nous sommes encouragés à
faire de l'activité physique non pas
pour brûler des calories mais pour le
plaisir je trouve que ça salit vraiment
bien avec l'activité physique
l'alimentation intuitif j'emmène
vraiment mes clients à arrêter de se
poser
à se reconnecter à leur bien-être qu'est
ce qu'ils ont envie qu est ce qu il veut
le faire
mais pour vrai ccc arrêter de se
stresser avec le poids cesser
complètement contre-productif
abandonnée l'image qu'on se fait de ce
qu'on devrait avoir changé un peu nos
habitudes se recentrer sur nous mêmes et
surtout lâché prise être un parfait et
en santé comme le 10 juin arrêtez d'être
en combat contre soi d'être en combat
pour l'alimentation être en combo pour
pour l'activité visée avec notre poids
on est dans le passé ou dans le futur on
veut atteindre le poids qu'on a déjà eu
où on est toujours dans la tente de
m'écrire ont fait pas passer notre vie à
vouloir changer de poids à vouloir
modifier notre corps une vial a bossé
mais je trouve que c'est une valeur
parce qu'une vie on a juste une fille
encore en agissant t c'est correct que
si on trouve que c'est plus beau métier
au moins que ça nous nuit sport
[Musique]